Thinking about the conclusions we drew about these graphs in terms of which ones
are functions and which one isn't, let's make a generalization about how we can
tell graphically what is a function. So in other words, how can we test
graphically that a given curve only has 1 y value for every x value? I'd like
you to complete this sentence to create this guideline for us. So if we draw
what kind of line on the same coordinate plane as any given function, the
functions curve should intersect that line some number or fewer times. Now this
is definitely a really tricky question, seriously. So if you have trouble with
this that is 100% fine. This is going to give us a really useful tool. So take a
second to consider the question.